Saint Gregory really gives us a
beautiful image and this is actually one
of my favorite images in the uh in the
life of Moses and I'm actually going to
read it to you because it is so amazing
it really is like if you want to
understand everything I do
it's pretty much contained in this text
and so
so when he says that when you remove the
the garments of skin and you enter into
the holy place where you move the
coverings and you come into the place
where God is manifesting himself in the
world
he says when we do this the knowledge of
truth will result and manifest itself
the full knowledge of being comes about
by purifying our opinion concerning
non-being
in my view the definition of Truth is
this not to have a mistaken apprehension
of being
falsehood is a kind of impression which
arises in the understanding about
non-being as though
what does not exist does in fact exist
but truth is the sure apprehension of
real being
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
with Jordan Peterson's daily wire Exodus
seminar in which I participated a few
months ago and which is streaming now on
daily wire
they're putting out episodes I think
once a week now I thought I would really
continue looking at Exodus as a kind of
compliment adding to the discussion
which I had
um and so last the last video I did was
on the first two chapters of Exodus
we're gonna do chapter three and chapter
four which is really the burning bush
this is one of my favorite parts of the
text but it's also one of my favorite
parts of Saint Gregory of nissa's
commentary on the text and so I'm going
to dive a little more into sangria of
Nissa in this particular episode and
we're going to look at what it is that's
going on in the story of the burning
bush leading all the way up to this one
of the strangest uh stories in scripture
the circumcision of Moses the Sun by the
hand of zipporah as God is coming to
kill someone either Moses or or Moses
his son in the in the um
in his tent and so I think I have a
little bit of insight to offer you of
course I sadly for that story I will not
be able to completely unlock the mystery
but I do have some insight I think I can
offer starting at the beginning of
chapter three of Exodus now Moses was
tending the flock of Jethro his
father-in-law the priest of Midian and
he led the flock to the back of the
desert and came to Horeb the Mountain of
God and the angel of the Lord appeared
to him in a flame of fire from the midst
of a bush so he looked and behold the
Bush was burning with fire but the Bush
was not consumed then Moses said I will
now turn aside and see this great sight
why the bush does not burn
so when the Lord saw that he turned
aside to look God called him from the
midst of the Bush and said Moses Moses
and he said here I am
then he said do not draw near this place
take off your sandals off your feet for
the place where you stand is Holy Ground
and so the first thing to understand
which is very important here is of
course the the importance of
understanding that as Moses is ascending
the mountain what we're going to see
this is going to be true
everywhere in this story which is that
Moses is a microcosm of Israel we have
to keep thinking in fractal structures
Moses is a microcosm of Israel the story
of Moses is a microcosm of what's going
to what's happening to Israel and so we
can see that Moses going up the mountain
here and seeing the burning bush in the
Mountain of God is a preview or as a
little version of what will later happen
when the entire nation of Israel is
gathered around the mountain and Moses
goes up the mountain to encounter God it
is very important to understand that if
we want to understand the symbolism
um most of you I hope that many of you
will have read Saint Gregory of nissa's
Life of Moses and you will see that
Saint Gregory takes certain things for
granted that is he takes certain
understandings for granted his text is
very slim and he presents things
sometimes which may look to people like
a kind of of jump in logic or kind of
jump in in understanding or analogy
let's say too much analogy but when you
look at the text you realize that his
analogies are deeply deeply uh grounded
in this structural vision of how the
text lays itself out one of the things
that Saint Gregory for example
emphasizes although I'm not sure it's
there in the Hebrew text but he says
that it is a thornbush it's a Bramble
Bush that he would have seen in the
desert in the mountain which is not
completely unfathomable considering that
you know those are the types of bushes
that can grow in deserts our Thorn
bushes and so the importance of
understanding that it is a thorn bush
can help you understand what it is
that's going on that is Moses is coming
up the mountain and he is encountering
two extremes he's encountering the fire
in the Thorns now the Thorns are of
course the Thorns of of the Fall that is
what's going on the bush represents the
the Fallen World right the fall that the
consequences of the fall and so he is
seeing the fire of God burning in the
inside the the consequence of the fall
but not totally consuming it not
consuming it there's these two things
that that exist together and so Saint
Gregory really sees this as an image of
the Incarnation and especially as an
image of the Incarnation based on the
notion of the Virgin and so we have uh
traditional icons in the in the Orthodox
Church where we will see the burning
bush represented as the mother of god
with her hands up with the image of
Christ in her Center and this is
something which comes in part for sure
from Saint Gregory directly because he
talks about how the burning bush is an
image of you know uh the virgin's
virginity not being consumed in the in
the um the manifestation of Christ but
it's not just about not being consumed
but also the possibility of of
manifesting God right the possibility of
manifesting God in the Incarnation this
is what we mean by not being consumed
because we have to understand that in
Exodus God is represented as this
all-consuming fire which will consume
everything if it's not connected to it
properly and so there has to be
of the proper relationship between God
and the world in order for what we see
in the burning bush to be possible which
is for God to be present in the world
without consuming it and so this is why
the burning bush is so important because
it is a kind of miraculous represent
miraculous event where God is present in
the world without completely consuming
it which is why it is an image of the
Incarnation ultimately for Christians
but why it is in some ways this the
beginning of what will be set up later
which is that God is going to manifest
to Moses the manner in which he can be
in a relationship with the world without
consuming it and that will imply a
hierarchy and a set of mediations which
will mediate let's say the the presence
of God down into the world in order to
to be able to to be there and so you can
see already that the question of
mediation is important in the story
because Moses immediately he covers his
face but it's interesting because there
is in the in the the approach to the
burning bush a uncovering and a covering
and so this is of course the mystery of
the of the revelation of God all the
time it is always this mystery of the
relationship between covering and
uncovering and so how things veils cover
the holy place but they in some ways
reveal the Holiness because even in
their veiling and so that's why there's
this mystery of a relationship between
veiling and unveiling in the idea of of
manifestation right because
the only way to see God is through
mediations but those mediations are at
the same time a covering and so that's
why on the one hand Moses removes the
sandals from his feet but then also
covers his face those two things are
kind of happening simultaneously to show
you this this mystery of how it is that
you can encounter uh how you can
encounter the infinite in the finite how
how can you do this what's important to
see here is of course the idea that
Moses removes his sandals in order to
come into the holy place like I said
it's important to understand the the
fractal nature of this saying Gregor
Nisa really points Us in the right
direction when he links the fact that
Moses removes his sandals in order to
come to the holy place and this removal
of the sandals is an image of
circumcision it is an image of removing
the animal garments of skin which God
gave to Adam and so God gives to Adam
these garments of skin which are there
to be a protection from the thorns and
now in order to you know and they're
right they're good to have these these
garments to protect you from the Thorns
but if you want to come into contact
with the manner in which God reveals
himself in the Thorns then you have to
remove the garments of skin in order to
be able to have that Revelation and so
it's deeply linked to the story of Adam
and Eve in the garden of Genesis
um but like I said it's deeply linked to
what will happen later and so saying
Gregory pointing us to the fact that he
removes the the sandals in order to come
into contact with God in the burning
bush is directly related to when Moses
goes up the mountain to receive the law
that what he will leave down there at
the bottom of the mountain will be the
golden calf the animality will stay at
the bottom and Saint Gregory points to
the fact that in the ascent
Moses it says in the text that the
animals should not touch them even touch
the mountain and that he sees this as
this image of animality which is lower
and has to be let's say removed in order
to come into contact with the revelation
of God
but when he come into the the Revelation
uh this moment where you encounter this
Saint Gregory really gives us a
beautiful image and this is actually one
of my favorite images in the uh in the
life of Moses and I'm actually going to
read it to you because it is so amazing
it really is like if you want to
understand everything I do
it's pretty much contained in this text
and so
so when he says that when you remove the
the garments of skin and you enter into
the holy place where you move the
coverings and you come into the place
where God is manifesting himself in the
world
he says when we do this the knowledge of
truth will result and manifest itself
the full knowledge of being comes about
by purifying our opinion concerning
non-being
in my view the definition of Truth is
this not to have a mistaken apprehension
of being
falsehood is a kind of impression which
arises in the understanding about
non-being as though
what does not exist does in fact exist
but truth is the sure apprehension of
real being
so whoever applies himself in quietness
to hire philosophical matters over a
long period of time will barely
apprehend what true being is that is
what possesses existence in its own
nature and what non-being is that is
what is existence only in appearance
with no self-subsisting nature
it seems to me that at the time of the
great Moses was instructed in the
theophany he came to know that none of
those things which are apprehended by
sense perception and contemplated by the
understanding really subsists but that
the Transcendent Essence and cause of
the Universe on which everything depends
alone subsists for even if the
understanding looks upon any other
existing things reason observed in in
absolutely none of them the
self-sufficiency by which they could
exist without participation in true
being on the other hand that which is
always the same neither increasing nor
diminishing immutable to all change
whether to better or worse for it is far
removed from the inferior and it has no
Superior standing in need of nothing
else alone desirable participated in by
all but not lessened by their
participation this is truly real being
and the apprehension of it is the
knowledge of Truth
that's what Saint Gregory of Nisa is
setting up for us here is the idea that
I've talked about several times on the
channel which is that things exist
he sets it up in an extreme way so he
says nothing exists on its own things
only exist to the extent that they are
dependent on self-subsisting existence
with that they are dependent on God and
if we wanted to use other words that
maybe can help you understand more being
we could say the good we've talked about
this that that that things are dependent
on their good they exist in their good
so although Saint Gregory he sets it up
as this radical distinction and it makes
sense to do that saying nothing exists
if they don't if they don't exist in God
there's a way in which we could say only
God fully exists because he is the the
end his he doesn't have other causes
above him he is the cause of all causes
he is self-subsistent existence and all
things depend on him for their existence
but you could also understand it
fractively in a way that is is suggested
in The Exodus text which is the things
exist in their goods and those goods the
intellectual let's say the physical
things exist in their intellectual goods
and those intellectual Goods also don't
have self-cent nature but it all scales
up and moves towards something like an
infinite good which which is the source
of all the other goods and the way which
they exists and so
anything which is grasp for itself and
we acted on it if we act on it as if we
think that it has independent existence
and existence in itself becomes an idol
and this is of course what is the whole
much of the story of Exodus is about
which is why you can understand for
example the story of the of the golden
calf because there's nothing wrong with
a golden calf but that if you try to
make it into a point of attention on its
own
then it becomes bad but if you see it as
scaling up towards higher and higher
Goods then it participates then it finds
being then it becomes something which
participates in this this transcended uh
possibility and so you can see that this
is true of anything we've talked about
this before it's true of of of any
action that you do whether it's the
normal actions of eating or you know
making money or working or loving other
people like all these things are good if
they scale up towards higher goods and
they become let's say they manifest
their illusion if you try to grasp them
for themselves and so if you if you
grasp them for the cells it's an
illusion but if you see how it is
connected to higher and higher beings
then it becomes good then it because
then it has its proper level of being
you could say and so this is of course
what Saint Gregory is pointing towards
and he's pointing towards how all of
these is is pointing towards let's say
the Incarnation as the very movement of
this as the very movement of the highest
into the lowest and how if things are
seen properly that this not only becomes
possible but becomes the very way in
which the world actually exists
and so Saint Gregory sees the image of
the burning bush essentially as a as an
image of ultimately of the Incarnation
which can be understood as the
possibility of the Transcendent to
manifest in the particular and so when
we look at all the other aspects of the
burning bush we're going to notice that
this is what is uh this is what he's
going to see almost everything in that
story as related to and it will make
sense and for people watch who watch my
content you'll understand it especially
if you understand it practically as
something which is true in the absolute
but is also true at every level that is
at every level that has a Transcendence
to it that has a good which is above the
particulars that this is true all the
time all the way up into the highest
Goods
all right and so let's continue
all right so then he said do not run
here to this place take your sandals off
your feet for the place where you stand
is Holy Ground like I said this is
circumcision it is removing of the
garments of skin wherever he said I am
the god of your father the god of
Abraham the god of Isaac the god of
Jacob and Moses hid his face for he was
afraid to look upon God
and the Lord said I have surely seen the
oppression of my people who are in Egypt
and have heard their cry because of
their task Masters for I know their
sorrows so I've come down to deliver
them out of the hand of the Egyptians
and to bring them up from that land to a
good and large land to a land flowing
with milk and honey to the place of the
Canaanites and the Hittites and the
amorites and the parasites and the
hivites and the jebusites now therefore
Behold The Cry of the children of Israel
has come to me and I have also seen the
oppression with which the Egyptians
oppressed them come now therefore I will
send you to Pharaoh that you may bring
my people the children of Israel out of
Egypt
so there are a few things to understand
in this Revelation the first thing is
that God presents himself as the god of
Moses's ancestors and this is important
because this is what in some ways is
happening fractally because you cannot
you have to understand the Israelites as
this this kind of scattered people in
Egypt that God has forgotten that God
doesn't remember that they also don't
really remember themselves and you know
aren't able to to uh to come together as
a people and exist as these as this
potential for the Egyptian tyranny and
so God is saying he's going to deliver
the Egyptians out of of Egypt but it's
important that he also connects himself
to the order of being that the
Israelites have which is he's saying you
know I am the god of your ancestors I
will you I will gather you back to
myself but I will also gather you back
to the identity in your father Abraham
and and your father father's Abraham
Isaac and Jacob and so he's he God is
going to do that at different levels and
it's important to understand because
you'll see that Israel when they leave
Egypt they're represented as a as a even
not the people that leave aren't
actually just the actual descendants of
Abraham they're they're that plus a
gathering of all kinds of people you
know they are mixed multitude and that
the the let's say the the the the
creation of these intermediary
structures of the giving of the law that
Moses will do will bind them together as
a nation and will create a hierarchy
amongst them even though some of them
aren't even actually descendants of uh
of Abraham
and if they agree to to follow the
Covenant that God will give them then it
will bind them to the identity and so
this is important because a lot of
people sometimes see that um
Christianity is somehow factitious
because there are places where Saint
Paul talks about how you are also
children of Abraham as Christians
because you you participate in this
Covenant but this is something which was
there in Exodus it's already there in
the in the Exodus story and so in the
version of the Christian version it's
only let's say expanded even more but
it's not new it's not something which
just comes out of nowhere but rather
Finds Its place in The Exodus story as
the manner in which the mixed multitudes
are able to cohere towards towards unity
and towards participation in Israel and
becoming becoming children of Israel
and so God says that he remembers Israel
and not only that but he sees Israel and
this is important in understanding the
manner in which first of all even how
creation was done we have to remember
when God creates he creates and then he
sees and he sees he evaluates when he
sees he he notices the phenomena that
he's created and then he evaluates that
it's good and in this he's doing the
opposite he's seeing that it's bad but
he is he is noticing let's say that's
really important uh because a lot of
what's going to happen has to do with
the problem of attention and noticing
and memory uh and so God remembers
Israel and so he wants to reconnect with
Israel but in some ways Israel is too
scattered Israel is too far from God we
could say in order to be able to
properly connect to Moses and so what
God has to do is he has to create and
all these intermediary structures these
mediating structures these veils is a
good way to understand it in order for
him to be able to connect with them but
he also has to remove the improper veils
and remove the the the improper aspect
of the Egyptians in order to be able to
join with Israel so it has to do with
exactly with what we saw in the right
away when Moses comes to the mountain he
has to cover his face but he removes his
sandals and so he's removing the
improper aspects of the the Egyptian
covering we could say or the animal
covering the the the uncircumcised flesh
but then he's also covering it fit his
face in order to manifest the proper
mediation in order to be in contact with
God and so this is something which we'll
you'll see if you understand it that way
there's a lot of the things that happen
that are going to that are going to make
sense so God says he's going to bring
Israel into the land of milk and honey
and uh it's interesting to understand
the land of milk and honey and to
understand that
you know what are those images like what
what does this represent and so the land
of milk and honey seems to represent
something like that that which is uh
tame the the best of what is close
that is the the uh the pure the uh
you know the tame animals that produce
milk or the mother that produces milk
the idea of something which is also in
some ways for uh for nourishing and then
the best of the wild or the best of that
which is barely
uh connected and so but then but that is
also extremely sweet and that seems to
be the honey and so because it's very
you know the idea of why
um honey is kosher in in uh in the laws
it's very it's ambiguous right it's like
it's it there are a few of these types
of foods which are a little ambiguous
um and so if you want to understand the
best image of the land of milk and honey
it really is an image of the diocese and
you see in Christianity you have this
image of Christ in the center with the
mother of God on his right hand and
Saint John The Foreigner on his left
hand and that really seems to be
something of what is represented here
which is the best of the right hand the
best of the left hand the best of that
which is close and nourishing and uh you
know and pure you could say and then the
best of that which is wild because of
course people would gather
honey in in the wild they would gather
it from they wouldn't they didn't
necessarily have uh honey the way that
we have it now that the best of that
which is wild and the best of the of the
wild prophet in the desert wearing the
garments of skin and so you have these
two extremes where God is saying this
will be the land which is Flowing of the
best of the two sides of of reality you
could say
um and so that's of course a very
interesting part of it
so God says he's going to send Moses as
his Envoy right towards the Egyptians
and he's going to deliver
Israel by him but then Moses comes back
to God and says but Moses said to God
who am I that I should go to pharaoh
that I should bring the children of
Israel out of Egypt
so he said I will certainly be with you
and this shall be assigned to you that I
have sent to you when you have brought
the people out of Egypt You Shall Serve
God on this mountain
then Moses said indeed when I come to
the children of Israel and say to them
the god of their fathers they sent me to
you and they say to me what is his name
what shall I say to them and God said to
Moses
I am who I am
and he said thus you shall say to the
children of Israel I am has sent me to
you
moreover God said to Moses thus you
shall say to the children of Israel the
Lord God of your fathers the god of
Abraham the god of Isaac and the god of
Jacob has sent me to you this is my name
Forever This is my Memorial to all
generations go and gather the Elders of
Israel together and say to them the Lord
God of your father is the god of Abraham
of Isaac and Jacob appear to me saying
I've surely visited you and seen what is
done to you in Egypt and I've said I
will bring you up out of the Affliction
of Egypt to the land of Canaanite and
the Hittites and the amorites and the
parasites and the hivites and the
jebusites to a land flowing with milk
and honey
then they will heed your voice and you
shall come you and the Elders of israels
to the king of Egypt and you shall say
to them the Lord God of the Hebrews has
met with us and now please let us go
three days journey into the Wilderness
that we may sacrifice to the Lord our
God
But be sure that the king of Egypt will
not let you go no not even by a mighty
hand so I will stretch out my hand and
strike Egypt with all my wonders which I
will do in in its midst and after that
he will let you go
and I will give this people favor in the
sight of the Egyptians that it shall be
when you go that you shall not go
empty-handed but every woman shall ask
of her neighbor namely of her who dwells
near her house articles of silver
articles of gold and clothing and you
shall put them on your sons and your
daughters so you shall plunder the
Egyptians
so in this text you can really see you
know how this connects with what I was
talking about before which is that when
Saint Gregor needs to talks about God
being being in itself being being that
has no other causes you can really
understand that in this text God says I
am that I am that is I am that which
named I'm the only thing that can name
itself you could say because it is he is
the origin of being he doesn't have
anybody anybody else naming him and he
all in some ways almost doesn't have a
name his name is simply being his name
is I am and so you can see that there's
a relationship right here because God
says tell them I am sent you true being
sent you but then he says then tell them
that I am the god of your ancestors that
is it connects fractally down the levels
from True being and being itself to the
way in which you recognize yourself to
have being that is how do you recognize
how does Israel have being it has being
by sharing a common origin in the
Patriarchs they have they have this
common ancestor and of course it makes
sense because this ancestor had a
covenant with being had a covenant with
God himself and so it all connects
together that this is the way in which
this is the way in which uh uh it it
works down the hierarchy and so if you
look at the if you look at the the text
I mean it's it's very interesting and so
God says I am being I am the god of your
fathers I am the way in which you
connect to to your identity I remember
you I have seen your scatteredness I've
seen your suffering I've seen that which
is breaking you apart and now I will
gather you back and how will I do that
you will come out and you will all come
to the mountain together and you will
gather together at the mountain and you
will worship me at this mountain and and
then you you know this is how you will
join together this is how all this is
going to happen and then I will
bring you to a land flowing with milk
and honey after that happens after we
are able to to after all this connection
has been done and you've remembered who
you are you're you are remembered
brought back together and you receive
something from above and now you will be
moved out towards the land of milk and
honey and so
what's interesting is that if you look
at the entire text you can really see
there's an interesting kind of hierarchy
just in in the way in which God presents
himself he starts with being and then he
ends with the idea that you are going to
plunder the Egyptians that if you're
going to take riches from the Egyptians
so he starts with being itself moves
down to Identity talks about Gathering
the people together and goes all the way
towards the edge and says this is also
how you're going to take from Potential
from The Stranger you're going to take
your possibilities and you're going to
gather them together as well and so it's
like this whole Cosmic image of how
being moves all the way down to even
into the idea of you know leaving Egypt
and Gathering the Gathering all the the
strains and this is important like the
idea of plundering the Egyptians is an
image which is very important in in the
commentary of secure givenessa but also
in other Church fathers where they talk
about this which is San Gregor Nisa
really represents the Egyptian as being
all that which is
not let's say which is Pagan which is
secular which is not directly coming
from the revelation of God this kind of
indirect aspect like I said uh
philosophy science all these other all
this other knowledge and Saint Gregory
talks about how you know we are called
to plunder the Egyptians that is take
which is good from this these this
outside knowledge and gather it together
towards being towards the highest being
and that is how it's going to find its
true value and so
you know the Egyptian is a tyrant if the
if the Egyptian rules over you but if
you are subject to God and you're
subject to the highest good then the the
what the Egyptian offered
becomes potential for for you and so
there's a this is interesting reverse
potential if you reverse relationship if
you remember in the first chapter the
first video I talked about how the
tyrant in the Egyptian wants to reduce
the Israelites to being potential for
his tyrannical rule well here you see a
similar structure but now it's seen as
being good that is
that which the Egyptians offers is
gathered together towards a higher
purpose not just the Tyrant but then all
the way up towards serving God serving
being itself and this is what Saint
Gregory talks about this is the text
this is why the text that I read from
you from Saint Gregory is so important
because it shows this this symbolic
structure that I've talked about in
terms of Dante that I've talked about in
different guises of how realities exist
together all the way up a hierarchy of
goods and it's presented very
beautifully
in this in this statement that God makes
so Moses isn't sure and this is going to
be important to understand Moses
hesitates of course and he says so then
Moses answered and said but suppose they
do not believe me or listen to my voice
suppose they say the Lord has not
appeared to you so the Lord said to him
what is in your hand he said
a rod and he said cast it on the ground
so he cast it on the ground and it
became a serpent and Moses fled from it
then the Lord said to Moses reach out
your hand and take it by the tail and he
reached out his hand and caught it and
became a rod in his hand
that they may believe that the Lord God
of their fathers the god of Abraham the
god of Isaac and the god of Jacob has
appeared to you
so what is going on here
is what just happened like it's just a
repetition of what just happened it's a
repetition of what God said when he said
I am that I am and then he says I am the
god of your fathers and he moves all the
way down and he says you will gather The
Riches of the Egyptians in service of
the highest God and so now God is
exemplifying it in practice a very
simple in a very simple way he's saying
he's saying you're holding a rod and
this Rod is the image of the vertical
like you could say it's the image of the
mountain it's the image of identity it's
the image you know it has the masculine
quality and so it's the image of the
name right it's that which which is
straight it's the it's the right and
then he says let go of it and as he lets
go of it then it becomes change it
becomes a serpent it becomes that which
is wavy that which moves from left to
right which doesn't have a direct uh
with a direction it becomes something
like uh
missing the mark it becomes potential it
becomes the the waters and that's why
it's also thrown on the ground so it you
know he's it's standing up he puts it
down on the ground and then it becomes
water it becomes shangy and Shifty and
all those things and then and then he
says grab it again right so let's say
grasp the potential and then you when he
grabs it by the tail then it turns back
into it recovers its identity and so
this is what God said he said you will
you will go to the to the Israelites in
Egypt and you will call them out of
Egypt and they will come and gather
around the mountain of God and then they
will become one people they will they
will become my people and I will be
their God and they'll be this vertical
relationship which will be established
um and so he's showing you how attention
Works basically right how things gather
together in attention
and move from potential into identity
and this is you know this is something
you can experience this is something
that you experience all the time you
move out into reality that is how you
you grasp that is what attention is it's
like you there's a quantity of phenomena
you grasp it mentally not just
physically but you also do it physically
as well and that's how you discover the
identity you gather it together into one
and then when you let go of it then you
discover its multiplicity you know and
so this is what John ravaki talks about
this you know all the time he talks
about what he calls optimal grip which
is the notion that when we when we hold
on to things physically we have to be
careful not to grasp them too tightly or
too Loosely we have to find the optimal
way in which we can we can we can hold
them and this is true physically but
it's also true in terms of categories in
terms of identities because identities
are made of of Multiplicity and unity
and so you have to be able to find that
balance between the two and here in the
text you see the movement from one
extreme to the other but in reality this
happens
sorry to use the word fractal all the
time but it happens at every level and
it happens subtly in terms of every
moment you're constantly judging between
letting go and grabbing the serpent uh
you're you're constantly uh judging
between the rod and the serpent between
that which is one that which is many
that which is stable that which is fluid
that which is that which has identity in
that which is changing because all of
that is part of reality so this is
really a very powerful image of what of
just how reality works
so Gregory needs to really he sees it
obviously as an image of the Incarnation
itself as the manner in which God can
move into creation and so when when you
know the the serpent when Moses lets go
of the rod then he becomes a serpent and
Saint Gregory goes as far as saying and
repeating the words of Saint Paul which
is that Christ became sin for us that
missing the Mark is what Christ became
and in becoming that
then he he it's in some ways returns it
to the father and let's say he becomes
the snake and the snake which will then
be re-gathered up into the rod and that
would be of course an image of the
Resurrection an image of the man which
Christ gathers all things up into into
the father
and so
that is the that is the the image and so
then if you understand that then you can
notice that the second image that Moses
gives
so furthermore the Lord said to him now
put your hand in your bosom and you put
his hand in his bosom and when he took
it out behold his hand was leprous like
snow and he said put your hand in your
bosom again so he put his hand in his
bosom again and Drew it out of his bosom
and behold it was restored like his
other flesh
then it will be if they do not believe
you or heed the message of the first
sign that they may believe the message
of this the latter sign
so you can notice that now we have the
similar image one was a vertical to
horizontal right A Rod to a snake on the
ground now it's the center to the
periphery and so he's saying you know
bring your hand into your bosom and when
you exit it it becomes it becomes
disease or it becomes leprous and then
when you bring it back then it becomes
healed and again San Gregory sees this
as an image of the Incarnation and as
the you know it's basically the same
image as the snake and the rod there is
one
possible difference is that there might
also be a hint that this in some ways
might be the opposite of the other one
and that is something that you can
ponder on yourself something that I've
thought about which is it has to do
possibly with an excess of Purity we the
idea of leprosy in the Old Testament the
idea of your skin becoming white is snow
seems to have something to do with an
excess of Purity uh and not exactly the
same as an excess of the snake but this
is something that I'm not 100 sure of
but if we take the story of the the the
story of uh of Miriam and Moses's
Ethiopian cushite wife that seems to be
what's going on is that is that you know
he a Miriam criticizes Moses for having
a dark wife and then she becomes as
white as snow and so it becomes like
it's like a it's like a funny it's not
funny but it's like an ironic punishment
where she becomes too too light and that
two light is actually a is a is a is an
excess of Purity but you could also
probably see it I mean for sure St
Gregory sees it as the idea of the
Incarnation and disease right he sees it
more in the sense of disease so
something healthy moves out into disease
and something disease moves back into
that which is healthy uh and so I think
that that's also completely appropriate
reading of this particular text
and so then you will have the last sign
verse 9 and it shall be if they do not
believe even these two signs or listen
to your voice that you shall take water
from the river and pour it on the dry
land the water which you take from the
river will become Blood on the dry land
and so here of course he is talking
about the plagues and you can kind of
understand that in some ways he's
hinting at the plagues from the
beginning the plagues are like a
exploded version of what it is that's
going on here in terms of the the sign
of something
untouched turning into blood now
as Christians it's very important to to
understand
what is going on here and also
understand
what at least in the Christian story
this is going to return now
where are the plagues leading to right
we're going to see this later when we
get to the actual place but the plagues
are leading to the final plague
which is the death of the firstborn
and the changing of water
into blood
leads to the death of the firstborn
ultimately
uh and you can understand it as a kind
of saturation of reality as well as
moving from
let's say that which doesn't have any
identity to that which is something like
it kind of controlled
a control breakdown of identity right
that's what wine is it's like the
extreme of fermentation and so in some
ways it's like a control decomposition
so you have Purity without any identity
then you have wine which is kind of
inebriating you also have the milk honey
situation here sorry I'm talking about
wine already but in in this is it's
blood but you can understand where I'm
going with this which is that in the
story of the winning of Kana it's it's
referring to the plagues of Egypt
because the changing of the water into
blood leads to the death of the
firstborn and now once you understand
that you can understand why the strange
story of the winning of Kana represented
represents itself that way which is why
is it that why is it that you know when
the mother of God says to Christ change
you know there's no wine there and he
knows he's going to change water into
wine that it means he's gonna die
it's like it's it's leading him to his
death this is deeply ingrained in the
story of exodus in the story of the
plagues but then you know
you'll see how the whole idea of the
death of the firstborn has a lot more
than you think
um a lot more than you think uh related
to it all right and so
then Moses said to the Lord oh my Lord
I'm not eloquent neither before nor
since you have spoken to your servant
but I am slow with speech and slow of
tongue
so the Lord said to him who has made
man's mouth or who makes the mute the
death the seeing or the blind have not I
the Lord now therefore go and I will be
with your mouth and teach you what you
shall say
but he said oh my Lord please send by
the hand of whoever else you may send so
the anger of the Lord was kindled
against Moses and he said is not Aaron
the levite your brother
I know that he can speak well and look
he is also coming out to meet you when
he sees you he will be glad in his heart
that you shall speak to him and put the
words in his mouth
and I will be with your mouth and with
his mouth and I will teach you what you
shall do so he shall be your spokesman
to the people
and he himself shall be as a mouth for
you and you shall be to him as God and
you shall take this rod in your hand
with which you shall do the signs
and so I hope by now you can see how
this is becoming connected together and
so God set up a
relationship of the way in which he is
being itself
and then also the way in which he is the
god of the ancestors of Moses the god of
the ancestors of Israel and the way in
which Israel
the place in which Israel binds together
and so now God is telling Moses to go
speak to be his spokesman right to be a
representative of him and Moses said I
am not able I cannot speak
and so now we're going to start to see
God set up
the intermediary structure between
himself and the world and it's going to
start already with Aaron now it's
important to understand
these things are they're they're a
little difficult to proceed but once you
start to perceive them you'll notice so
for example a good example would be
in the story of King David the
Israelites ask for a king and then God
is angry and in some ways doesn't want
to give them a king
but then ultimately relents give them a
king but then the king becomes the tool
of God in the world the one who builds
the temple he becomes the one who builds
the house for God and so
sometimes we see the text a little too
simply and so we say you know kingship
is bad because God didn't want Israel to
have a king but that's not how it works
it's that in some ways you could say
that
that which is below
because of its insufficiency requires
mediation in order for God to manifest
himself in the world and so Moses asks
for
something to mediate and then God is
angry but then God ultimately relents
and that's the way in which it happened
God gives Moses uh it's an extension of
himself and so here you really see the
fractal relationship getting set up it's
pretty clear God says to Moses
Aaron will be your mouth right
and then you will be my mouth in some
ways and you will be as God to him you
will and and I mean it's pretty wild
just to that that's written in the text
it's like your Aaron's God will be you
and you and I will be your God obviously
not completely but in this context there
is this this self-same relationship this
fractal relationship going down the
manner in which mediation appears and so
and so you you can see how even though
let's say even you could also get the
sense that Moses is Aaron's heart
you know emote and that's why it says
like he's glad in his heart when he
meets Moses because Moses is one level
lower than God and then he speaks to
Aaron and then Aaron speaks to the
people so so Moses appears as hidden
behind a veil now Aaron is his Veil that
Moses is constantly you know hiding
himself behind a veil in the sense of
God but then also for the people like
when he comes down the mountain and puts
a veil on his face well God is doing the
same to Moses now he's saying I'm going
to put a veil in your face
you know and and thou this out this
thing that I'm putting in front of you
that will manifest you in the world will
be will be Aaron and so
it's pretty interesting and Saint
Gregory of needs to really
gives us a powerful image and this is
one like I said one of my favorite this
whole part is my one of my favorite
aspects of San Diego of nisa's
commentary because here
um San Diego needs to talks about Aaron
as the helper
and he really presented as the Angel and
the demon right the angel on the right
shoulder and the demon on the left
shoulder and so the guide the helper the
this this aspect of Moses which can
either bring him up or bring him down
um and you can understand it in terms of
a supplement in terms of the the idea of
mediation or the problem of mediation
because mediation always causes a
problem which is the problem that Saint
Gregor Miser brings up in his text which
is that if you create mediating levels
between with that which is above and
that which is below and those mediating
levels are always in danger that people
will see them as having being in
themselves will it attach to them too
much and because of that they will
appear as an illusion as a mistake as an
error and so Aaron is exactly that think
about it God says to to Moses Aaron will
be the one doing the signs and
manifesting you in the world so he's
like one step down on the hierarchy of
mediation
but then who makes the golden calf
Aaron makes the golden calf right that's
the problem of mediation it's the
problem of creating these levels uh
coming down but it's but it's also
inevitable and it has to be done
appropriately and we could say that all
of the book of Exodus is about
understanding the way in which these
mediating levels exist and the ultimate
image of that is going to be the
Tabernacle because the Tabernacle that's
what the Tabernacle is the Tabernacle is
the manner in which the presence of God
is mediated in the world through ritual
through space through layers through
through veils through sacrifice to
offering up receiving down all of this
is what the Tabernacle is and that's why
the Tabernacle is an image of reality
and that's of course the way that Saint
Gregory presents it in his own text as
well
all right and so let's continue
verse 18. so Moses went and returned to
Jethro his father-in-law and said to him
please let me go and return to my
brethren who are in Egypt and see
whether they are still alive
and Jethro said to Moses go in peace
now the Lord said to Moses in Midian
go return to Egypt for all the men who
sought your life are dead
then Moses took his wife and his sons
and set on a donkey and he returned to
the land of Egypt and Moses took the rod
of God in his hand and the Lord said to
Moses when you go back to Egypt see that
you do all the Wonders before Pharaoh
which I've put in your hand but I will
harden his heart so that he will not let
the people go
then you shall say to Pharaoh thus says
the Lord Israel is my son my firstborn
so I say to you let my son go so that he
may serve me but if you refuse to let
him go indeed I will kill your son your
Force born
you can see being set up right the idea
of the giving of the firstborn
and how it is related to
how reality Works which is that
Egypt has to let God's firstborn go
in order to be made sacred in order to
be given up towards God
and though he says if he doesn't do that
then I will take his firstborn
and we're going to talk about this a
little later when we get to the actual
plagues but this is obviously it's the
plagues are being set up in this text
and a lot of people really struggle to
understand the next part which is coming
so I'm not going to go too much in terms
of understanding the idea of the giving
up of the firstborn and why that's
important we'll talk about that when we
get to the place because we've already
been going for a while now but when we
read the next part maybe it'll help you
already see hopefully if you've been
listening uh to me for a while you'll
start to understand at least what's
going on here so the next part is one of
the strangest texts in the entire Bible
um and so
here it is
and it came to pass on the way at the
encampment that the Lord met him and
sought to kill him
then zipporah took a sharp Stone and cut
off the foreskin of her son and cast it
at Moses's feet
and said surely you are a husband of
blood to me
so he let him go then she said you are a
husband of blood because of the
circumcision
and so what is happening in this story
now
there's a few things going on and it's a
very ambiguous text the way it's written
is ambiguous it means that when even
when the way that it's translated
uh it's translated in a way that's
trying to kind of guess at what the
meaning is because uh first of all it
says
and it came to pass on the way of the
encampment that the Lord met him and
sought to kill him and so the question
is who is he who is he trying to kill
it's not clear whether it's Moses or the
son of Moses
uh and then zapport took a sharp Zone
and cut off the force Universe gun and
cast it at Moses's feet now again in the
text in the Hebrew text at least it just
says cast it at his feet now it doesn't
say whose feet it is whether it's Moses
or the Sun and it's actually possibly
not just his feet it might be his
genitals because in the text the
genitals and the feet in the Bible the
feet are a euphemism for genitals uh and
you see that in the story of Ruth you
could say the story of Ruth is like the
opposite of this in some ways of what's
going on here because
where it's related to this let's say
where the strange woman uncovers the
feet of Boaz and here you have the
strange woman circumcising her son and
then putting the the foreskin on the
feet of Moses now
at this point if you it's funny because
because uh Saint gregar Nissa doesn't go
very far into interpreting this he he
basically I'll give you his
interpretation which is excellent but he
doesn't go far but if you see this you
can understand why is it that Saint
Gregory makes the analogies between
Egyptian Stranger In general stranger
foreskin and sandals
and garments of skin where he makes
these all related because in the actual
text there is a euphemism between the
feet and the genitals and so removing
the sandals and removing the the
foreskin is an is is there in the actual
language of the text as being related in
terms of what it is that's going on and
so
the the first important thing to
understand is where the text is placed
people I've always seen people tend to
want to interpret this little sequence
as being a self-contained event but we
have to see it as following the text
before which is Israel is my son my
firstborn let them you know let my son
go so that he may serve me
but if you refuse to let him go I will
kill your son your firstborn and then
you have a text where Moses is going
back to Egypt and his son is not
circumcised and now God wants to come
and kill someone in the camp either
Moses or his son
and in order to prevent that the
zipporah removes the garments of skin
around her son around around uh uh
remove the Garment skin around her son
and then cast it at touches Moses's feet
with them and so it's like it's very
mysterious but it has to do in some ways
with the relationship with the stranger
which we've been talking about the whole
time and this is what Saint Gregory of
Nissa says he says
he understands of course the son of
Moses from zipporah as the fruit of our
Union with all that is Pagan all that is
secular all that is all the secular
signs all these things and so
the fruit of that Union is Moses's son
and now in order for
things to be proper right in order for
for for his son to be given up to God
right let my son go so that he may serve
me
then he has to be purified from the
negative aspects of the strange he has
to be circumcised all the the negative
aspects of the Pagan knowledge of of
secular knowledge you know all the
dangerous captivating aspects of them
has to have to be weaned and and uh have
to be um uh let's say cut off in order
to be able to present the son of his
Union with with the stranger as being
acceptable to God and so Saint Gregory
uses the example he says you know in
philosophers or in Greek philosophy they
have this idea of the immortality of the
Soul which is something that that is the
right uh the right way of thinking but
you can imagine that the fact that the
Greeks taught reincarnation or that
taught other aspects which were not
let's say which were kind of were off
key then those things have to be pruned
so we can read Plato we can get from
Plato the uh a an insight and a help
even in the language and in the the
terminology to help us formulate and
understand our Christianity but it has
to be circumcised you have to remove the
excess and the things that don't that
don't fit ultimately
um
and so that's one thing that's going on
but there's another thing that's going
on like in terms of structure folks like
it's very fascinating think about it
just in terms of the story
Moses goes up the mountain
and then he has to remove his garments
of skin in order to enter into the
sacred place
and now Moses is going back to Egypt
and so his wife removes the foreskin of
her son and she she touches his feet
with them she she puts them on his feet
and so it seems like she's also adding
sandals to Moses so that he can move out
and go back into the Strange Land that
seems to be at least part of what is
going on there but like I said it is a
very it is a very strange text but I
think it's also possible that some of
the ambiguity in the text serves the
serves the meaning of the text but for
sure you cannot interpret this part of
the story without understanding that it
has to do with sacrificing the firstborn
and giving the firstborn up to God which
is related to
removing the the the the the excess and
then giving up to to to God so but it
like I said very mysterious so um
all right and so then we get to the last
part and the Lord said to Aaron go into
the Wilderness to meet Moses so he went
and met him on the Mountain of God and
kissed him so Moses told Aaron all the
words of the Lord who had sent him and
all the signs which had commanded him
then Moses and Aaron went and gathered
together all the Elders of the children
of Israel and Aaron spoke all the words
which God had spoken to Moses then he
did the signs and the sight of the
people so that people believed and when
they heard that the Lord had visited the
children of Israel and that he had
looked on their Affliction then they
bowed their heads and worshiped
oh so of course this seems like an
obvious thing it's reads very easily but
you have to look at it properly and this
has something to do with the manner in
which
multiplicity becomes one the way that
I've been telling you guys for years now
so
there's the hierarchy right Moses and
Aaron go down and then Aaron becomes the
spoke man for Moses he becomes a spokman
and then God says I have seen from above
I've seen you and now I'm manifesting
myself through this hierarchy down to
you and what that looks like is the
Gathering of the children of Israel
together
and the worshiping that which is above
and so gathering in order to give
attention to that which is that binds us
so they listen to Aaron they listen to
Moses and they listen to God and they
worship God
because that is how let's say that is
how multiplicity binds to one through
attention to a common good something
which is beyond the multiplicity and
what that does is it gathers
multiplicity into one and ultimately in
terms of the Transcendent it looks like
attention a different level but
ultimately it becomes worship and it
also means that they bowed their heads
right they submit themselves to that
which is above and that's how they
that's how it all comes together and so
this in some ways you could say is an
image a little image of what is coming
later right because it says Aaron met
Moses at the Mountain of God this is the
same Mountain that that who's they're
going to later and then he comes down
the mountain
and then he gathers the people together
and they worship and so it's a little
image of what is coming later when they
leave Egypt and they go out into the
Wilderness and then it's going to happen
at a grander scale and at a more let's
say at a larger
in a way that will bind them let's say
more permanently we could say so that
they can actually become a nation but
that that also that they can be in a
relationship with God through these
these mediations so I hope this was
helpful like I like I've said you before
like I told you before this is a
compliment to the videos that I'm doing
with uh that I did with daily wire on
Exodus make sure you check that out the
discussion is very interesting I've been
getting some great feedback from people
who have watched the uh the video so I'm
excited to see that people are enjoying
it it's going to continue and we're also
going to do a second part in January
recording the second part from the law
until the end and I will try to track
these as the videos come out with daily
wire I'll try to track them with some
with some videos on my own so you can
get a little more of what I think of the
book of Exodus so thanks everybody for
your attention and I will talk to you
very soon